♪♪
-Hey, guys. I'm here at
the 50th Street subway station
right below Rockefeller Center,
and Miley Cyrus and I are about
to go onto the subway platform
and start busking in disguise.
No one knows
that this is going to happen.
that it's Miley Cyrus.
Let's do this.
-Alright, Bart. Let's party!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Jolene" plays ]
[ Train rails screeching ]
♪♪
-Yee-haw!
-Yeah.
-♪ Jolene, Jolene,
Jolene, Jole-e-e-ne ♪
♪ I'm begging of you,
please don't take my man ♪
♪ Jolene, Jolene, Jolene,
Jole-e-e-ne ♪
♪ Please don't take him
just because you can ♪
You sound good there, Bart.
-Thanks.
-♪ Your beauty
is beyond compare ♪
♪ With flaming locks
of auburn hair ♪
♪ With ivory skin
and eyes of emerald green ♪
[ People cheering ]
Yee-haw!
♪ Jolene, Jolene, Jolene,
Jole-e-e-ne ♪
♪ Please don't take him
just because you can ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I had to have
this talk with you.
My happiness,
it depends on you.
♪ And whatever you decide
to do, Jolene ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
♪ Jolene ♪
-♪ Jolene ♪
-♪ Jolene, Jole-e-e-ne
-♪ Jole-e-e-ne ♪
-♪ Please don't take him
just because you ca-a-a-a-n ♪
-Thank you.
-Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you very much.
I am Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're gonna do one more song
for you.
This is Miley Cyrus!
[ Shouts indistinctly ]
[ "Party in the U.S.A." plays ]
-This is my first time
at the subway station.
This is exciting [bleep] for me.
♪ I hopped off the plane
at L.A.X. ♪
♪ With a dream and my cardigan ♪
♪ Welcome to the land
of fame excess ♪
♪ Whoa, am I gonna fit in? ♪
♪ I jumped in the cab,
here I am for the first time ♪
♪ Look to my right,
and I see the Hollywood sign ♪
♪ This is all so crazy ♪
♪ Everybody seems so famous,
hey ♪
♪ My tummy's turning,
and I'm feeling kinda homesick ♪
♪ Too much pressure,
and I'm nervous ♪
♪ That's when the taxi man
turned on the radio ♪
♪ And a Jay-Z song was on ♪
♪ So I put my hands up,
they're playing my song ♪
♪ The butterflies fly away ♪
♪ I'm nodding my head
like, "Yeah" ♪
Now your hips.
♪ Moving my hips
like, "Yeah" ♪
♪ Got my hands up,
playing my song ♪
♪ I know I'm gonna be okay ♪
-♪ Ye-e-e-e-ah ♪
-It's a party in the subway!
-♪ So I put my hands up,
they're playing my song ♪
♪ The butterflies fly away ♪
♪ I'm nodding my head
like, "Yeah" ♪
♪ Moving my hips
-♪ Got my hands up,
playing my song ♪
♪ You know I'm gonna be okay ♪
Oh, yeah!
-♪ Ye-e-e-e-ah ♪
-♪ It's a party in the U.S.A. ♪
-Last one!
♪ Ye-e-e-e-ah ♪
♪ It's a party in the U.S.A. ♪
-Miley Cyrus,
ladies and gentlemen.
New York City,
that's how we do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music ends ]
-That was all you, Bart.
-Hey guys, I'm here at
the 50th Street subway station
right below Rockefeller Center
with Adam Levine
and James Valentine of Maroon 5.
The three of us about to go
on to the subway platform
and start busking in disguise.
No one knows
that this is going to happen,
nobody knows
that it is Maroon 5.
Let's do this.
-Yeah!
[ Train rails screeching ]
♪♪
[ Harmonica playing ]
-♪ Well,
this thing called love ♪
♪ I just can't handle it ♪
♪ This thing ♪
-♪ This thing ♪
-♪ Called love ♪
-♪ I must get round to it ♪
♪ I ain't ready,
crazy little thing called love ♪
♪ There goes my baby ♪
♪ She knows
how to rock 'n' roll ♪
♪ She drives me crazy ♪
♪ She gives me hot
and cold fever ♪
♪ She leaves me in a cool,
cool sweat ♪
♪♪
♪ I gotta be cool ♪
♪ Relax ♪
♪ Get hip and get on my tracks ♪
♪ Take a back seat hitch-hike ♪
♪ And take a long ride
on my motorbike ♪
♪ Get ready,
crazy little thing called love ♪
♪ Oh, yeah,
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're going to do one more song
for you guys,
but first I'd just like
to say hello.
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is Maroon 5!
Give it up, New York City!
-I wish I could leave that on.
♪♪
♪ I'm hurting, baby,
I'm broken down ♪
♪ I need your loving, loving,
I need it now ♪
♪ When I'm without you
I'm something weak ♪
♪ You got me begging, begging,
I'm on my knees ♪
♪ 'Cause really I don't care
where you are ♪
♪ I just want to be there
♪ And I got to get
one little taste ♪
♪ Sugar ♪
-♪ Sugar ♪
-♪ Yes, please ♪
-♪ Won't you come
and put it down on me? ♪
♪ Right here ♪
-♪ Right here ♪
-♪ Yes, I need ♪
-♪ I need ♪
-♪ Little love
and little sympathy ♪
♪ Yeah, you show me good loving,
make it all right ♪
♪ Need a little sweetness
in my life ♪
-♪ Your sugar ♪
-♪ Sugar ♪
-♪ Yes, please ♪
-♪ Won't you come
and put it down on me? ♪
-Does that sound good,
New York City?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Right here, I need ♪
♪ Little love
and little sympathy ♪
-Come on, sing it loud!
-♪ Yeah, you show me good
loving, make it all right ♪
♪ Need a little sweetness
in my life ♪
♪ Sugar ♪
-♪ Sugar ♪
-♪ Yes, please ♪
-♪ Won't you come
and put it down on me? ♪
♪ Won't you come
[ Cheers and applause ]
and put it down on me? ♪
-Maroon 5!
Thank you, New York City!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, guys, I'm here at the
42nd Street subway station,
right below Grand Central,
and U2 is about to go
on the subway platform
and start busking in disguise.
No one knows
this is gonna happen.
Nobody knows that it's U2.
They're just gonna go out there
and do it.
And I'm wearing
these glasses here
with this special camera in it
so I can get some
decent footage
of the crowd here
in the greatest city
in the world, New York City.
Let's do this.
Let's play some music.
Alright, New Yorkers!
Let's go!
Here we go!
-Let's go!
[ Harmonica plays ]
-Let's go! Let's do this!
[ Train rails screeching ]
Guys, give money,
support your local artists!
You like what you hear,
give them some money.
This is a local artist here.
New Yorkers,
they play birthdays,
they play bar mitzvahs,
they'll play your party.
You guys like what you hear,
support your local artists!
Some New Yorkers here,
why don't you come over?
Any change will help.
You got a dollar?
-♪ I have climbed
the highest mountains ♪
♪ I have run
through the fields ♪
-You guys want to support
your local artists?
-♪ Only to be with you ♪
♪ Only to be with you ♪
♪ I have run, I have crawled ♪
♪ I have scaled
these city walls ♪
♪ These city walls ♪
♪ Only to be with you ♪
♪ But I still haven't found
what I'm looking for ♪
-♪ What I'm looking for ♪
-Oh, it's not working,
not working this way, you guys.
Not working. No, no, no.
Plan B! Plan B!
Plan B, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's go to plan B!
[ "Desire" plays ]
U2!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Lover, I'm off the streets ♪
♪ Gonna go where
the bright lights ♪
♪ And the big city meet ♪
♪ With a red guitar, on fire ♪
♪ Desire ♪
[ Crowd cheers ]
♪♪
♪ I'm in a fever
when I'm beside her ♪
♪ Desire ♪
♪ Burning ♪
♪ I'm burning ♪
Everybody in 42nd tube station!
[ Crowd cheers ]
♪♪
Come on! Come on!
♪ She's the dollars ♪
♪ She's my protection ♪
♪ She is a promise ♪
♪ In the year of election ♪
♪ Oh, sister,
I can't let you go ♪
♪ Like a preacher
stealin' hearts ♪
♪ At a travellin' show ♪
♪ For love or money,
money, m-m-m-money ♪
♪ M-m-m-m-m-m-m-money ♪
♪ Mo, money, my, my, my ♪
♪ And the fever,
gettin' higher ♪
♪ Desire ♪
-Alright!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
-You guys, U2,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, guys, I'm here at 50th
Street subway station,
right below Rockefeller Center,
with Alanis Morissette.
She and I are about to go
onto the subway platform
and start busting in disguise.
Nobody knows about this.
No one knows
that it's me and Alanis.
Let's do this.
-Let's do this.
-Do we go through here?
♪♪
Good evening, everybody.
We'd like to sing
a couple songs for you.
I hope you enjoy.
Happy holidays.
[ "The Little Drummer Boy"
plays ]
-♪ Come, they told me ♪
♪ Pa-rum pum pum pum ♪
♪♪
♪ A newborn king to see ♪
♪ Pa-rum pum pum pum ♪
♪♪
♪ Our finest gifts we bring ♪
♪ Pa-rum pum pum pum ♪
♪♪
♪ To lay before the king ♪
♪ Pa-rum pum pum pum ♪
♪ Rum pum pum pum,
rum pum pum pum ♪
♪♪
♪ Shall I play for you? ♪
♪ Pa-rum pum pum pum ♪
♪ Me and my drum ♪
♪ Me and my dru-u-m ♪
-Thank you very much,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy, happy, happy holidays,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My name is, uh, Jimmy Fallon.
And this is Alanis Morissette
right here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "You Oughta Know" plays ]
-♪ I want you to know ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ That I'm happy for you ♪
[ Laughs ]
♪ I wish nothing but
the best for you both ♪
♪ An older version of me ♪
♪ Is she perverted like me? ♪
♪ Would she go down on you
in a theater? ♪
♪ Does she speak eloquently? ♪
♪ And would she
have your baby? ♪
♪ I'm sure she'd make
a really excellent mother ♪
♪ 'Cause the love that you gave
that we made ♪
♪ Wasn't able to make it
enough for you ♪
♪ To be open wide, no ♪
♪ And every time
you speak her name ♪
♪ Does she know
how you told me ♪
♪ You'd hold me
until you died? ♪
♪ Till you died,
but you're still alive ♪
♪ And I'm here to remind you ♪
♪ Of the mess you left
when you went away ♪
♪ It's not fair to deny me ♪
♪ Of the cross I bear
that you gave to me ♪
♪ You, you, you oughta know ♪
-Thank you very much,
everybody.
Happy holidays!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alanis Morissette!
Thank you, New York City!